I'm going to give you the best piece of  ice I got you need to more than anything  think about two core things in my  opinion one you have to at all costs not  beat your own self up with yourself yes  at all cost fair enough it's yesh you  need to really be your own biggest fan  instead of critiquing everything number  2 momentsintime you've got to wrap your  head around how young you actually are  you have to wrap your head around how  early in the process this is and how  this is just a very small moment in time  yeah very quickly I can tell you you  need to get every voice out of your head  besides yourself and you need to love  yourself you will win can't live your  life based on other people's point of  view  [Music]